this morning thousands of flags cover
the national mall
in washington honoring the nearly 200
000 americans
killed by the coronavirus this image
stands in stark contrast with president
trump's comment last night
saying the virus effects in his words
virtually nobody
our lead national correspondent david
begno has spent months
speaking to americans paying the price
in this pandemic david good morning
good morning you know i was thinking
before we came on the air anthony what's
one thing that just about every family
has told us over the last several months
and it is this
take this seriously this morning i want
to introduce you to ricordo
he lives in arizona he's lost nine
members
of his family to coronavirus he also
lost his job his livelihood
in the catering business and as he's
trying to find where the family's going
to get their next paycheck
his wife is about to deliver a baby
most people don't don't think it's real
until it comes knocking on their door
the feeling of loss associated with
coronavirus just will not go away for
ricardo aguirre
he spoke to us just hours before he
attended a rosary for his father
jose de jesus aguirre sanchez
he died on september 11th after a
four-month battle with coronavirus
do you know how he contracted the virus
no i do not all i know is that my mother
is the one that started having the
symptoms first
and from there it was my dad myself
my wife my two kids and then my brother
over the last seven days the average
rate of new coronavirus infections
nationwide
increased to roughly 40 000 every day
and on friday the cdc published a
significant change to its
guidance on how the virus spreads it
said that
in addition to spreading through
respiratory droplets produced when an
infected person sneezes or coughs
another
main way that the virus can spread is
through aerosols
small airborne particles which are
produced by talking
breathing or even singing it also said
the virus can travel
further than six feet through the air
particularly in
indoor environments like restaurants but
on monday the cdc
scrubbed that guidance from its website
saying it was a draft that was posted by
mistake
many of us read the draft that was up
and thought
wow they finally get it this is really
good information
this is what is supported by the body of
science information out there
dr michael osterholm is an infectious
disease expert
at the university of minnesota he says
that flip-flop
yet again by the cdc is hurting the
agency's credibility
at the worst possible time if they had
just left it up
you would have found many of the leading
scientists
outside of cdc congratulating them for
an outstanding job
instead they now are drawing the fire of
incompetency again
we got an email from the cdc explaining
what happened a spokesperson told us the
bottom line is aerosol transmission is
possible
but it's not the main way the
coronavirus spreads
look dr osterholm and the other experts
say the cdc has
got to get it right and they've got to
do it consistently and i'll tell you one
thing they've all been consistent on the
cdc
and the leading experts is that masks
work
and we should wear them tony david thank
you very much